the truman show was one of the better
films of the 90s it was also we know now
the second to last good movie that jim
carrey would ever star in that's not
really relevant to our purposes today
what is relevant is a scene about
halfway through the movie featuring ed
harris's character christoph the
director and creator of the giant
reality show that jim carrey's truman
has unwittingly been living and starring
in since birth
during an interview with some kind of
news magazine show kristoff has asked
why truman had never up until that point
himself asked any questions about the
nature of his world how is it that he
lived his whole adult life never came to
realize or even suspect
that everything's fake and all of his
friends and family members are actors
everything about his reality is
engineered manufactured
kristoff answers quickly he says we
accept the reality of the world with
which we are presented it's as simple as
that
perhaps one of the truest lines ever
spoken in a hollywood film
and we live in a reality that is nearly
as contrived and concocted as the one
that truman inhabited the only
difference is that the guy walking past
us in the street is not an actor he's
not an agent of this deception he is one
of the deceived just like the rest of us
or most of us
also truman was filmed against his will
or his knowledge that's the case for us
some of the time no doubt
but we also choose to be on camera some
of us more than others as you can see
but the main similarity is that like
truman
reality is presented to us i think the
wording there is important reality
presented
we're not so much encountering reality
or engaging with it certainly not
discovering it
we sit back passively and allow reality
whatever bits of it that our overlords
deem appropriate for viewing
to be presented to us
our reality is not so much
staged like a television production as
it is curated
we view reality mostly through screens
we look at screens more than we look at
anything else we look at screens more
than we look at our children's faces
and inside those screens we find a
version of the world
that someone else
our kristoff and there are many of them
not just one
thinks we ought to be shown
it's not reality it's reality as told by
as curated by cnn
twitter mark zuckerberg corporate media
and so on
they are the directors of our own
personal truman show they present
reality and most people simply accept it
as presented
and that's why for example on this
monday november 29th 2021 the major
terrorist attack that occurred on on
sunday november 21st 2021 just a little
over one week ago
has essentially been erased
as far as our reality curators are
concerned it never happened
eight days ago may as well have been 8
000 years ago
nine children are still in the hospital
one child died in the intervening days
bringing the the death total to a six
to go along with the dozens of severe
injuries
it was a horrific attack a massacre
little children and old ladies mowed
down on the street while waving pom-poms
and singing christmas carols
one of the most grotesque and tragic and
infuriating things you will ever see and
you can see it because it was all
documented on multiple cameras from
multiple angles
if the corporate media media our
curators were simply yet cynically
interested in sensationalism and ratings
and nothing more if that's all they
cared about
this story would be one of the only
things they talked about for weeks
but their cynicism is more insidious and
more surreptitious i think than that
their goals are also quite a bit larger
grander
they want to create a certain kind of
reality a reality governed by their
ideological and political needs and this
event a jaw-dropping and certainly
newsworthy event
does not fit into that picture so it's
been in one week
erased
completely you know uh as you know i am
a theocratic fascist dictator i'm a
philanthropist i'm a virginia resident
uh i am a uh a cult leader but i still
don't feel like i get all of the respect
i deserve even with all of those titles
which is why i have now become
this is very real lord matt walsh i have
used established titles to become my to
become a real lord and so that's i
expect to be addressed this way uh if
you want to be a lord as well establish
titles is your opportunity to earn the
title of lord or lady and gain the
respect that you deserve all you need is
a one square foot plot of land in
scotland established titles is a project
based on historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english if your
title pack your in your title pack you
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
which you can see right here looks it
looks very official because it is
and i'll put this um i haven't told my
wife this yet but this is going right
this is the first thing people see when
they walk in our house so they know what
they're dealing with and how to address
me your certificate will include a
unique plot number which uh with which
you can see the exact location of your
land and as we're approaching christmas
i should also mention that it's the best
last minute gift ever the best way to
surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends boyfriends or even family
you could even get a couple pack for you
and your partner where you can get
adjoining plots of land with this
certificate you could officially change
your name to lord or lady and get it on
your credit card plane tickets etc you
can get it on your dating profiles as
well i mean if you really want to
impress someone
or make them think you're a megalomaniac
one way or another not sure how that
will work out but
plus for those with scottish heritage
it's a great way to connect to their
family roots plus established titles
commits to preserving the woodlands not
only in scotland but around the planet
they have partnerships with global
charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future to help with our uh
uh with our efforts to you know reforest
the world which you know something that
i care deeply about as an
environmentalist and for every order
they receive a tree is planted
established titles is having a great
limited time sale so go to
establishtitles.com
matt walsh to save 10 off today remember
to use the discount code matt walsh or
just click the link below that's
establishedtitles.com
matt walsh or just click the link below
yesterday cnn issued what will likely be
one of its last reports on the subject
and uh it did it in a highly curated way
here's the headline
waukesha will hold a moment of silence
today marking one week since a car drove
through a city christmas parade killing
six people and injuring scores of others
a car
drove through the christmas parade
was it a tesla self-driving car was it a
car from a pixar film with a mind of its
own
outside of those possibilities cars
don't drive
saying a car drove through a parade is
like a sports writer reporting that a
bat hit a home run or a shoe kicked a
field goal
in reality the actual reality not the
curated kind
the car was being driven by a human
being and that human being has a name
daryl brooks
he also has a very relevant history of
violent crimes of all types including
sex crimes against children that somehow
had not yet landed him behind bars for
any significant stretch of time and he
had motivations
we may not know his specific motivations
mostly because we can only rely on the
curators to tell us something like that
unless we go to the prison and try to
ask him ourselves
but we can take note of his blm
sympathies his anti-white posts online
his open encouragement of violence
against white people
and we could take all that and
reasonably conclude that this was almost
certainly an anti-white terrorist attack
a hate crime
that doesn't fit within the reality that
our curators wish to present and so the
entire event
is thrown into a giant hole and buried
now within a couple of days
um they got us back on track right they
got us back to talking about the kinds
of things that they want us to talk
about in our curated reality
black on white crime essentially does
not exist and is always justified
whenever it does occur
also in this contrived version of the
world
non-white victims are ignored
for racist reasons
the very people who are ignoring the
white victims in waukesha and indeed
ignoring them because they are white
have now gotten back to insisting that
only white victims get attention
a few days ago the daily beast reported
on an hbo documentary called black and
missing
which argues that the media doesn't pay
attention to stories about black missing
persons
the daily beast tweeted
quote can you name five missing black
women director gita gambier's latest
documentary hbo's black and missing
tackles this question and is
unfortunately very timely in large part
because of the gabby potido case
can you name five missing black women uh
no i can't
but um of course
nobody can name five missing people of
any color
nobody can
i guarantee this right now you cannot
name five currently missing white women
or even one currently missing white
woman
you can't
the whole the whole framing of this
thing is completely ridiculous
missing people go missing all of the
time in this country
unfortunately
it can't all be national news almost
none of it ever is
and that's why you can't name them off
the top of your head
however
somebody driving their car intentionally
through a christmas parade
and murdering six people including a
child
that is or should be a major national
event
and yet you know who else nobody can
name off the top of their heads the
victims in waukesha
their names by the way were tamara
durand jane coolich lyanna owen virginia
sorensen wilhelm hospital and
eight-year-old jackson sparks
they died terrible and painful deaths
and now the corporate media wants them
to suffer a death of another kind
by erasing their memories completely
and we shouldn't allow that to happen
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content